the art of losing isn't hard to master
so many things seem filled with the
intent to be lost that their lost is no
disaster feels incomplete ilysm the poem
ends just when it ought to be picking up
steam I'm tired I'll take a trip ah the
geographic cure terrific except you
can't escape yourself Elizabeth Bishop
welcome to Brazil
this is me I designed this all myself
every inch of it how is it here
we're dispute bit up your known bothers
as much we can't all be as proud of our
work as you are I hear one of my poems
and I'm mortified I want you to stay
let's adopt abate he'll buy me a baby so
that you can have an affair with another
woman that's what you've always wanted
to make a family for us so this will be
your studio it's perfect
[Music]
shooting stars in your black bright
formation Elizabeth you want a Pulitzer
I have always felt alien here in Brazil
you treat me like a sister and I have
never felt more at home
you don't know her she screws everything
up live without you can't survive
without me doctor
[Music]
where did you learn to speak such good
English by reading poems honey
[Music]
you